المستقبلية وزيادة التجنيد
واعادة المتقاعدين الى الخدمة
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
على مرسوم ينص على تسهيل منح
خلال فترة العملية العسكرية
الخاصة. بينما ينتقل الروس الى
بزيارة كييب. فهل ينهيها صاحب
العينين الضيقتين? وهنا يوقع
مواقع للقوات الروسية مقابل
انسحاب الجيش الاوكراني من محيط
حيث كشفت صحيفة واشنطن بوست
الامريكية عن وثائق مسربة
يبقى تحت سيطرة الاوكرانيين سوى
كيلومتر ونصف الكيلو متر مربع.
ومؤسس مجموعة فاغنري فيجيني
بريجوجن الذي اصبح حديث الساعة.
باخموت. فيشتد الدمار ويؤجل
الحسم لكن القوات الروسية كما
في اوكرانيا بثقلهما العسكري مع
تصعيد وروايات متضاربة في
الذي صرح به المتحدث باسم رئيس
الوزراء البريطاني ريشيسوناك ردا
ليعتبر قائد القوات البرية
الاوكرانية ان التقدم الذي تحرزه
اذا ماذا عن بقية الاسلحة
كالصواريخ بعيدة المدى مثلا ايها
فرنسا المدلل ماكرون يعد بمزيد
من الدعم الفرنسي عسكريا لكييف
بوعده للغربيين. ومن الموعد
الغرامي والحضن البريطاني. ننتقل
الدمار. وقال الناطق باسم
الرئاسة الروسية ديمتري بيسكوف
موسكو فورا حيث حذر الكرملين من
ان شحنات الاسلحة البريطانية
حيث وعد ريشيسوناك بارسال مئات
الطائرات بدون طيار بعيدة المدى
زيلانسك وسوناك خلال زيارة
الرئيس الاوكراني الى بريطانيا
تعلنها للمرشحين. حاولوا مرة
اخرى. المحرقة الروسية. ثقة كييف
العسكري الاوروبي ينهمر نحو
اوكرانيا. هنا عناق حار بين
السلام. بوتين يحضر مكافأة دسمة
للمنضمين للجيش وسقوط اكثر من
والصواريخ. فما الذي يجري معارك
جوية بين روسيا والناتو وهجوم
موسكو تبدأ درسها ولندن ترد
بتزويد كييف بمئات الطائرات
الدب الروسي.
الصيني يستعد لغزو تايوان
بالتدريب على حرب المدن
مرة اخرى. ولفتت الصحيفة ايضا
الى ان السلطات الصينية لجأت الى
ثانية الاحد الثامنة والعشرين من
مايو. بريطانيا تكثف دعمها
نجوم السماء. افادت صحيفة
الجارديان البريطانية ان الجيش
بالطيران من البحر والتي يطلق
عليها اسم النسر الواقع وهو المع
الهيئة العليا للانتخابات
التركية انه لم يحصل اي مرشح في
الدورية التابعة لحلف الناتو فوق
بحر البلطيق كانتا تتجهان صوب
تلك الطرق لافتقاد الجيش الصيني
خبرة الحرب الفعلية. اكد رئيس
الانتخابات الرئاسية على الاصوات
الكافية لفوزه وتقرر اجراء جولة
لاوكرانيا بالاسلحة متجاهلة
مصيرا محتوما قد يجرها لمواجهة
ان مقاتلة روسية من طراز سو سبعة
وعشرين طردت طائرتين من طائرات
حرب اخرى لكن في الجو هذه المرة.
فقد اعلنت وزارة الدفاع الروسية
الحدود الروسية. الاحداث
والتطورات. تمكن الجيش الجزائري
من شراء اربع طائرات اطفاء
برمائية روسية من طراز المشهورة
الجنسية الروسية اجانب الذين
ابرموا عقودا مع الجيش الروسي
الاوكراني والروس. حيث يبدأ
الممثل الخاص للصين للشؤون
الوراسية لهوي جولة اوروبية لحل
النزاع في اوكرانيا ويفتتح جولته
ريبوشن لم يصمت ورد على الفور
ساخرا بقوله يبدو انني احارب من
اجل روسيا. لكن في الوقت نفسه
الرئيس الاوكرانيسكي يتبع
اليمنى. ومن مسعرات الحرب الى
خطط الاطفاء الصينية لحرب
باخموت. مضيفة ان المسؤولين
الاوكرانيين رفضوا راحة لعدم
تعليماتي? وبالتالي فان اليد
اليسرى في حال حرب مع اليد
ثقتهم في قائد فاجنر واعتقادهم
بان الامر قد ينضوي على خدعة.
فهل يوجه طباخ بوتين طعنة غدر
لجيش بلاده حقا? ما رأيكم انتم?
للبنتاجون ان بريجوجن عرض على
مسؤولين اوكرانيين الكشف عن
الشمالي للمدينة. قائد مجموعة
فاغنر الروسية شخص مثير للجدل.
النهاية بعد زوال دخان المعارك.
ليأتي الدور على طباخ بوتين
افجيني قال ان قواته تقدمت في
مدينة باخموت خمسمائة متر ولن
وسائر منطقة دومبا الشرقي
اوكرانيا. والحقيقة ستكشف في
ستمائة وثلاثين عسكريا اوكرانيا
خلال يوم واحد. اما الاجابة
هذه الهجمات والضربات. اليس هناك
خسائر وضحايا هؤلاء لتجيبنا هنا
الاوكرانية لا تكف عن اعلان
انتصاراتها في المنكوبة ومحيطها
المحايدة فخذوها منا ايها
الاصدقاء. حيث يرمي طرف النزاع
القوات الروسية نفذت اكثر من
اربعين غارة وعشرات الضربات
باخموت الشمال مضيفة في بيانها
ان ستة واربعين اشتباكا وقعت مع
الصاروخية واستخدمت مسيرات في
هجماتها شرقي البلاد. فيا لكل
القوات الروسية في مقاطعة
بمقاطعة واشارت الهيئة الى ان
تصرح ان القوات الاوكرانية افشلت
هجمات للقوات الروسية في ضواحي
ان قواته سدت الفراغ الذي خلفه
تراجع القوات الروسية في الجناح
الدفاع الروسية حيث اعلنت
الوزارة الروسية تحييد اكثر من
المنطقة وبحسب قائد الجيش
الاوكراني اعلنت عن اول نجاح
هي الخطوة التالية يا هذا? وهنا
هيئة الاركان العامة الاوكرانية
بالتحديد في مدينة باخموت وبعد
اشهر طويلة من بدء القتال في
الانجليز ومن البارفان الفرنسي
الى رائحة البارود الاوكراني
بريطانيا مثل هذه الخطط؟ هل
الطائرات وحدها هي من ستسبب
على سؤال بشأن خطط تزويد كييف
بطائرات مقاتلة بانه لا توجد لدى
لهجومها المضاد واستعادت السيطرة
على عشر مناطق بضواحي المدينة.
سابقة لاوانها بعض الشيء بحسب
صحيفة بوليتكو. وهو الشيء ذاته
مواجهة مباشرة مع روسيا؟ ولذلك
يخشى الاوروبيون ارسالها لكييف
لكن باريس تعتبر قضية الامداد
المحتمل لطائرات مقاتلة الى كييف
القوات الاوكرانية في باخموت هو
اول خطوة للدفاع عن المدينة. فما
من طراز ستوم شادو وعشر قذائف من
راجمة هايمارز وهكذا يفي بوتين
من جسر لندن الى برج ايفل لتكتمل
قصة الحب الاوروبي. هنا فتى
سبعة صواريخ هارم المضادة
للرادار وصاروخ كروز بعيد المدى
عسكري. وبعد ايام من تسليم
بريطانيا لكييف صواريخ بعيدة
المدى اعلنت الدفاع الروسية تمكن
انظمة الدفاع الجوي من اعتراض
اوكرانيا بالسلاح. واضاف ان
عمليات التسليم هذه لن يكون لها
تأثير كبير على مسار الصراع.
وهنا موسكو تعزز تصريحاتها برد
ان بريطانيا تطمح لوضع نفسها
بمقدمة الدول التي تواصل اغراق
وصواريخ الدفاع الجوي وانظمة
جوية الى اوكرانيا. لتأتي هنا
الجديدة لاوكرانيا التي اعلنتها
لندن ستتسبب في المزيد من
الجزائر تتمناها كل الدول
العربية والانتخابات التركية
بواشنطن اهتزت والزينسكي يستمر
التحشيد في اوروبا والدعم
تايوان بطريقة غريبة. وبوتين
يرسل هدية عسكرية فاخرة الى
ستمائة جندي اوكراني خلال اربع
وعشرين ساعة الصين تتحضر لاجتياح
روسيا بريطانيا تعدت حدودها ويجب
ان نعطيها درسا كي لا تنسى.
كييف المضاد يعلن عن اول نجاح
له. والصين تبدأ اولى خطوات